normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government I want
to jump to uh this story it's a tweet
from the account end wokeness end
wokeness tweets Target outdid itself
this year for Christmas and uh the first
image I've seen before it is what I
would describe as gay nutcrackers okay
I'm not that is not meant to be derisive
that is quite literally what it is it is
it is a nutcracker which many are
familiar with but it's uh blue holding a
pride flag with a rainbow hat and then
there's a very happy I guess Yeti and
unicorn and then there's this image
which depicts a series of white and
black Santa Clauses in wheelchairs
holding presence now okay when I saw
this I thought this is fake okay it was
like I think Shu on head made a video 10
years ago a joke about how diversity is
going to result in a trans non-binary
you know person of color in a wheelchair
like that was a joke she made and now
I'm seeing this image and so I I I I I
said I don't know about this and so I
Googled it ladies and gentlemen you can
order your Santa in a wheelchair holding
gift Fabric and they have the options of
in black or white and now look and it's
already on sale how much is it I can't
see it uh $2 with like $7 shipping or
something let's find I $7 I almost want
to buy a whole bunch of them but I also
kind of don't just give away company
Christmas no because I don't want to
support it but look if I was going to
buy it it would be like a novelty gag
gift making fun of wokeness they're
selling them legitimately and it's it's
kind of it's It's look if you are a a a
other otherly abled person of color and
you would like to purchase the Santa
Claus then I'm glad the option exists
for you I have no problem with the free
market providing if there are people who
have this lived experience and they
would like to be represented on a
Christmas tree then the market shall
provide but Target as a massive uh I
believe they're multinational but a
massive National Corporation they
there're I know Australia's Got a fake
version that they stole from us yeah but
uh who are they really selling to the
answer is very obvious white liberal
women that's who wants to buy this who
want to show their children look anyone
can be anything at any time it's uh what
they call what um impact it's like
impact investment but this is like the
the the refu tunnel of the impact
investment it's impact sales they're
putting it out in the open for people to
see what they want them to think about
and they don't even care if these things
don't sell
probably this is this is so wrong I'm
sorry this is so wrong it's they're say
people are saying it's the black it's
black paraplegic Santa and I'm like this
is insulting to people okay they have
turned them into a joke and I thought
the best question of the night was
Lauren who asked how's he going to get
his wheelchair down the chimney right
doesn't make any sense I thought I
thought somebody was making fun of
Target making fun of wokeness and then I
was like it's real we need to put uh
those those ramps but in for Christmas
everyone needs to get a ramp on their
front door otherwise you're
discriminating it's the fake thing
that's a fake version of a guy that's
fake no you need a ramp up to your roof
yep it's your chimy but I mean the
question is like who specifically is the
I mean aside from like white liberal
women but it's like a very specific
group of people professors celebrate
Christmas but also really want to
indulge in the wokeness which I like is
also are we sort of expecting a lot of
um you know paraplegic people to
suddenly appear on earth like why do we
need so many of them this could have
been one Etsy business that did really
well but instead Target is like everyone
knows someone in a wheelchair which
feels more like disturbing to me on some
but that's the thing like with all this
woke stuff whether it's paning to to
women or to black people in wheelchairs
who aspir to be Santa it's not actually
about the group they're representing
it's about the activists who who see it
as a virtue signal yeah I remember as a
kid being told that I could be Santa but
it's just a weird thing like you have to
oh he has to be just like me has to be
in a wheelchair too he like well you
think be better flying around the world
if you have wheelchair it's about that
time of year should we talk have the
Santa debate the santa santa santa
retire CU he's in a wheelchair now S no
no no listen listen Okay Ian I know
where you're going with this do we tell
kids if Santa is real that's what I'm
talking about and I think there's a
bigger question now on top of this I
don't know that we can answer that
question until we answer the question of
how do you explain to children that
there is black paraplegic Santa and
white sis heteronormative Santa no I'm
I'm telling my kids the only Santa is
black and in a wheelchair no I'm going
to take the FDR approach we're going to
hide the wheelchair we're going to just
like cover it up constantly no Scandal
was that Santa was always in a
wheelchair they regrowing when take
photos with people now hold on I go hold
on there where is where is Black Santa
with a Cocker implant mhm
he could be wearing him he's got thick
hair we don't know we can't see perhaps
where's trans Santa yeah he's coming
soon and that's the horror that's the
horror of the season now which is like
what are they to poor Santa who can't
defend himself okay so the Marvels just
came out right yeah and it bombed it's
the worst MCU opening in in the Marvel
franchise history and it's because
people just don't care for these
woke bad story lines where they just
hamfist in politics and when when people
started complaining back in the day
about how they like made anolin anolin
played like a black woman and people are
like yo I don't care about black actors
getting lead roles I care that you're
taking historical figures and characters
and changing their race like The Little
Mermaid South Park made a really great
point about this in the latest uh show
they did the panda verse the special
where PC principal is yelling at the
kids saying you just don't like black
people and they're like no we don't like
that you take an existing character and
turn it into a black woman they were
like Miles Morales is awesome he's his
own character and has like an alternate
history storyline they gave him which we
understand like people like there's a
lot of superheroes that have same
superpowers as other
superheroes this is gone One Step Beyond
and they're now
taking I I I it's religious and
traditional figures and now race
swapping them and and like look I know
we've seen this because 10 years ago
there was an argument on Tumblr whether
or not be toen was black and this is
what yes absolutely well is he no was he
ahead of time no of course not that this
is what they tried doing they tried
claiming that Samus Aaron the game
character was trans so for those that
aren't familiar Samus Aaron is the star
of the video game Metroid the Metroid
series and at the end of the NES game if
you like beat it in the right way or
whatever for the credits it shows the
character take the helmet off and it's
like super it's like eight eight bit or
whatever but there's long blonde hair
like aha you played a woman this whole
time and it was like about if you type
in Justin Bailey as your password you
can play as the woman oh zero Su you get
a the wave gun automatically you start
with it in the first one NES in Metroid
in the first Metroid Justin Bailey NES
yeah really wow and so what happens then
is a bunch of trans activists started
arguing well Samus Aaron is 6' three and
you know like 180 pounds therefore that
proves Samos was actually trans and they
tried they tried doing these things they
all they're trying to do is rewrite
cultural history and take it over that's
part of what is happening right now with
Target making black paraplegic Santa
well I mean sorry go ahead you go first
well I was going to say to this is a
tangent at this point but to Ian's
question about the whole Santa debate
I'm actually very anti- Santa because
Santa is not a I mean St Nicholas is a
religious figure but Santa the modern
iteration of Santa is basically just a
way to shove consumerism down our
throats by people who are not Christians
who are secularists and who only want to
make money do you think the people who
had designed that Santa are Christians
who celebrate Christmas nope do you
think all the people also I'm a very
against Santa movies have you noticed
that nowadays a Christmas movie it's all
about Santa and gifts and a secular
message it's a way to undermine
channelmark channel it's about everyone
ending up together getting married it
undermined the family unit for me
because it made me distrust my parents
not only did they lie to me for 10 years
yeah and then I found out I was like
what else are they lying to me about it
was terrible they would I I didn't
appreciate them every year around
Christmas when they would be the ones
that would bring me the gifts it it
should have been a bonding experience
for the family and that's this Soviet
communist uh consumer crap splitting up
the nuclear family yet again with now
your parent can't be the the hero this
year I think there are really
interesting ways to talk about Santa cuz
I like the like folklore aspect of it I
think it's fun to have like imaginative
opportunities for kids um I wouldn't
necessarily introduce this to your kids
but David sederis is a short story
author who has a really funny um essay
about at dinner parties he'll ask people
as an icebreaker and what does your
country tell you about Santa and it
changes and if you haven't heard it you
should definitely look it up it's really
funny uh I think it is interesting that
I grew up with uh the rert books where
which are like a British children's
series and Santa lives on a cloud and in
America we learn he lives in the North
Pole like there are ways to talk about
this in an interesting way it's just sad
that America Santa now is like you know
disabled I I care less about the skin
color so much as like what is he doing
how is he getting in his sled do we have
ADA accommodations at the North Pole you
know what I mean like introduces a level
of bureaucracy to this like kind of
mystical story that other like lots of
cultures tell um and it makes us seem
lame I will say the best is the the
Tibetan myth of Santa Claus where they
would every every winter their Yurts
would get covered up to the chimney and
they'd have to climb out the chimney and
go to the pine trees and they'd find
these mushrooms growing these white and
red amonita muscaria and the reindeer
would be eating them and they'd go and
they'd collect the mushrooms they'd come
back they'd CL climb down the chimney
and then hang the mushrooms up in socks
above the fire to dry overnight what and
then the next morning they boil them and
make tea with them every culture has
like various check out the myth of
psychedelic Santa it's crazy it's it's
it's all the color is the same it's the
red and white myth sorry from what I
understand the Orthodox Church they they
have like the Feats of St Nicholas that
they actually take pretty seriously so
when I say I'm anti- Santa I'm not anti
that but I I don't support personally
hates Santa yeah I don't support modern
consumerist especially black wheelchair
Santa who was St Nicholas what' he do
you know what that is a good what is St
Nicholas was a I don't know exactly
where it was somewhere in Eastern Europe
is what they think somewhere like turkey
people have said like the actual story
comes from you're right about the am
muscaria stuff from I've heard about
that as well um regarding like the the
color like the red and white and
everything like that but apparently like
it had to do with like he was a dude
that went around and helped some girl
get doy to get married I think initially
and that became Santa supports marriage
he's so trash this is the best thing
I've ever heard I sh this Santa I'm
wondering what the lore is as to how
Santa became paraplegic I the Imp down
chimney well nose didn't go off and he
got bucked out of the sled that's why I
say like this is insulting to people
like the implication is that Santa that
had some kind of terrible accident or
he's faking it's rough or he's just
getting older to get tips at the mall
maybe maybe I was going to go with he's
getting older you know he's got some
some arthritis in his knees from
climbing up and down the chimney so
maybe it's time to retire Santa and then
they'll introduce Mrs Claus or just call
her santet or something I'm going to go
I'm going to go with uh Santa did a uh
720 on the mega ramp and then when he
was going up for a varal 540 he clipped
the coping and flipped forward
shattering his ankles jeez and so it's
not a permanent thing and it's not he's
not a paraplegic it's just that he's got
serious leg damage cuz he was in the X
Games last
year needs a wheelchair that's I like
that that makes it sound tougher I like
that version of American how about how
about Santa got shot down flying over
Eastern Europe that's more line I
thought you were going to say Santa did
911 you going to blame Putin for Santa's
wheelchair injury that's rude I mean you
could like merge all of the current
things right black Trans Santa is only
disabled because of War Vladimir Putin
ordered Sant to be shot down right and
that's why we have to send money to
Ukraine could be a rally around flag
that finally makes sense hold on this is
what we thought at first but new
intelligent suggest it was Hamas that so
now we've got to provide funding for
Israel uh did you guys grow up with the
Christmas movie uh Grandma Got Run Over
by a Reindeer it's like you guys need to
watch it immediately I can't wait for
the Christmas season yeah like Santa
killed the lady right what well over
she's like in a hospital being taken
care of by don't spoil it for people you
guys get to watch it this K the guy this
Christmas season you should check it out
but it'll be like that except it'll be
like who shot Santa Claus you know you
you you never heard the song uh Grandma
Got Run Over By I've heard that song
before like and then they made a movie I
guess I don't know which came first yeah
I the movie first the song is by Elmo
and py from 1979 yeah the gag is that
you can say there's such thing as Santa
but as for me and Grandpa We Believe
yeah Grand one run over by a reindeer
walking home from my house Christmas Eve
it's a classic Christmas Tale yeah I
thought everybody knew that one you know
put a little Christmas cheer into this
conversation they figured out at Rice
University how to weave Nano threads
carbon Nano threads through broken
severed spine and then the spine finds
itself and regrows back together and
they've got mice with completely severed
spines that are able to walk again so
what you're saying is Santa may walk
again yeah Tim would you rather have a
Target insemination kit or a Target
paraplegic Black Santa for Christmas
just I'm just wondering I would love to
just like here's the problem I would
love to buy a thousand of the black
paric Santas to give us gifts but to
make fun of Target and wokeness and the
problem is I don't want to give money to
people who are serious yeah you know if
it was like the end wokeness account
announced they were selling these things
as jokes I'd buy a bunch of them and
give them out to people but the fact
that Target is legitimately selling
these things makes me be like well I
don't want to give him money now if you
bought it on Etsy you pick up some of
Lauren soap and then some Santas I
figured it out Target's trying to play
Both Sides mhm they know that people who
think it's hilarious will buy it to make
fun of them and they're going to make
money either way people who genuinely
support it will also buy it Target is
ultimately on its own side with
capitalism yeah the market shall provide
there is a market for us to buy black PA
plgic Santa because it's a mockery of
woke ideology and we think it's funny I
would just really like to see uh photos
from you know like probably December
24th maybe you know into January of
people in their clearance section at
Target and see how much these are
selling for then well is it is it that's
where all their best Progressive stuff
goes or lows where they actually have
the black blowup Santas no how big
they're like the big ones that you put
on the front yard oh wow I I saw I
forget where we were last year but I saw
those and I was like all right I like
the pictures of japanes Jesus wacky
waving inflatable arm flailing tub man
well Jesus you like no no the uh they do
have a dancing 58 inch African-American
dancing Santa at Lowe's dancing Santa I
bet the dancing is good he's
$200 I will I will buy both he's
animatronic not inflatable but maybe
that's but maybe they have more all kind
of stuff thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net